ていた
[音楽]
競合としが紹介して
するのはこちら馬頭琴という楽器です
こちらに感じがありますね馬の頭本性
頭が付いている楽器です
自分がなぜこの楽器を始めたことかとか文化についてちょっと今日は話したいと思い
ました
はい私の出身のモンゴルです
みんなモンゴルと言ったら草原のイメージばっかりですよね
でもウランバートルシティはとても今はきれいになっています
今私はあの土木の勉強しています橋とか
道路とかまちづくり自分をまたもっとウランバートルきれいにしたいなと思っていま
の勉強横浜で国立大学で
勉強をし始めました
こっちが本当のモンゴルだと思いますね
馬がたくさん動物がたくさんいます後ろにはゲイルと言いますねいけるいけるというの
は
えっとモンゴル人たちのペンとみたいなものです
夏のシーズンですこれは夏のシーズンに文言の人たちは動物たちのために
草食べる草がありますね種を求めて引っ越しをしています
なのでどこかに住所はありません
みんな自分たちの種を探して
引っ越しをしていますそんなモンゴルの遊牧民の生活の中で生まれたのがこちらの
ば統計になります馬頭琴というと日本でとても有名なお話があります
この
通報の白い馬
このスーホの白い馬というのは日本の黒五小学校2年生で子どもたちみんな勉強してい
ます
同様話かちょっと簡単にするとこの馬を持っているのは数歩です
吸う方が自分の詩ローマを見つけましたとても大きくなるまで大切に育てたんですけど
ある事件があって馬がなくなってしまいます
とても悲しかった彼は馬の
体の皮とか数字骨を使って最初にば刀剣をつくったというふうに言われています
実は私はモンゴル人ですけど
馬頭琴に初めて出会ったのはこのお話なんです
ちょっと不思議ですよねモンゴル人何日本の絵本で馬頭琴を知っている
なんでかというと私は子供の頃に北海道に住んでいました
北海道に7年ほど住んでいて日本の小学校に通っていて
日本の子どもたちと勉強してました
自分はなんかモンゴル人だとはあまり思ったことはその時はなかったです
である日学校に行ったら今日は
スーホーの白い馬の勉強しますと言いました先生がなにそれちょっとかっこいいじゃん
と思ってお話し聞いたらモンゴルの話私の生まれた国の話でしたそしたらある日本
エンジンのミュージシャンの人が来て私の小学校で
馬頭琴の演奏しました
めっちゃかっこよかったです
私の国の楽器 f こんな素晴らしい書があるんだ
初めて知りました
今私は日本の大学に通っていますが
8春休み2月3月にはそのミュージシャンの方のちょっと真似をしていろんな小学校に
行っています
小学校に行って馬頭琴の演奏して自分がこの馬頭琴はどういう楽器ですか
どういう文化から生まれた楽器でスカート子供たちに紹介しています
その日本人のミュージシャンの方に私がもらった
突破東金という文化をまた伝える
不思議ですよね日本人から今度はモンゴル人がまた戻ってくる感じです
今日はこの後にば刀剣を演奏したいと思います
で
今日このスピーチをお願いされて
何を話したらいいか全然分からなくてで自分が何をやってるんだろうと google
で調べたんですね
そしたら馬頭琴は無形文化財となくていました
google に書いてありました
人類の文化的活動によって生み出された
向けの文化的称賛前半
つまりモンゴルの人たちが長い間生活してきた文化が今こういうふうに形になって
色んな人の手を渡ってきています
その間には日本人だったり僕みたいなちょっと特別な例で日本で馬頭琴を初めて知った
人とかそういうふうに
文化というものは必ずしもその国の人が
やるべきことじゃないその人じゃなくていろんな人は興味持ってどんどん発信していけ
ばもうボルト角に国境関係なくいろんなところでみんなが楽しめるものだと私は思って
いますちょっと話はそろそろにして皆さん聞きたいでしょうからちょっとパーティーの
怨嗟をこれから始めたいと思います
持っています
最初に演奏する曲はあの
もルーンプールゾーンという曲ですこれはどういう意味ですかというと
と埋まって皆さっき話がありましたね抜刀県と言ったら本当に馬の曲がたくさんあるん
ですねその中でも馬の走っている
その音とかリズムを
曲にした曲がありますそれでは皆さんお楽しみください
[音楽]
ふーん
me
[音楽]
ぶームーン
[拍手]
ni
[音楽]
ぐうっ
ブーブー do はロシア
[笑い]
[音楽]
ブーバーし
ロリ
[音楽]
[笑い]
ううううううっうぅうう
me
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーブー j
ん
[拍手]
ちょっとモンゴルっぽい曲でしょう今の次にまたもう医局員させんですけどこちらも
モンゴルの8文化とか伝統についての曲です
で
本当は馬頭琴はもっとね丹代さんがやったらめっちゃかっこいいんです他にもモンゴル
の楽器と一緒にやるともっとかっこいいんです
でもそういうメンバー今日ちょっと集めることができなかったのでちょっと知りにその
仲間たちの曲方
入れてきたのでそれと一緒に馬頭琴を少し演奏したいと思います
はい
お願いします
[音楽]
nd 4 noooooo
ni
me
goo
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
ああああああ
par あの
re
これは
1不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
me
ni
goo
car
ああああああ
ふーん
[音楽]
ああああああ
goo
ううううううっ
うううう
[音楽]
ムーラ
voodoo
うううう2
goo
ムーラン
ni
産んだ子 w
[音楽]
dl
エロパロ
[音楽]
はぁ
改善しています